les drogues psychédéliques comme le lsd
la mescaline les champignons magiques
pourraient être utilisés pour leurs
effets thérapeutiques
les chercheurs s'intéressent de plus en
plus malgré des résultats peu probants
de telles recherches dans les années 60
michel bonsoir de quoi s'agit-il
qu'est ce que c'est que cette médecine
psychédélique c'est sérieux même si
serré usap lui semble extraordinaire
mais non des chercheurs s'y intéressent
pour des cibles et des maladies très
précise avec des drogues très précises
regardons ensemble
donc vous avez raison effectivement
c'est à l'elysée la mescaline et les
champignons magiques ont vu regarder
dans les effets positifs une chose en
particulier le rôle sur la sérotonine
qui est une molécule de centrales dans
le cerveau qui modulent bien des shows
dont la dépression on y reviendra
et naturellement la conscience altérée
me lisent effets négatifs les
hallucinations les psychoses ont retenu
beaucoup de chercheurs ce que l'on vise
bien c'est les dépendances l'anxiété et
la dépression on aimerait contrôler un
peu mieux ça avec ça alors pourquoi
es-tu 17 mai les cris quand on connaît
les effets secondaires qui sont assez
négatif oui les effets secondaires sont
négatifs
alors ces jeunes chercheurs là ont des
protocoles différente d'il ya soixante
ans c'est beaucoup plus éthique alors
donc c'est un consentement éclairé avec
des comités éthiques on travaille avec
de toutes petites doses pour des
périodes très courtes donc une approche
très différente et diège les résultats
déjà intéressant bien pour l'anxiété on
a deux bonnes études une avec le lsd et
l'autre que les champignons magiques
on a réussi à réduire de façon
considérable l'anxiété reliait des
maladies mortelles chronique et pour les
dépendances à l'alcool une bonne étude
qui réduit de moitié les effets des
champignons magiques
il ya quand même des bémols field il ya
des inquiétudes
alors il ya beaucoup il ya où il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et la première je
crois qu'il faut mettre ça en
perspective
il faut qu'ils arrivent à démontrer
trois choses principal qu'ont réussi à
avoir un effet thérapeutique on a trouvé
des dosages et qu'on n'a pas d'effets
secondaires négatifs alors ça va prendre
encore des années avant que les
gouvernements qui vont recevoir sa élit
médecins puissent regarder et voir si on
va ministre et ça ou pas ça se fera
certainement en conjonction avec les
psychothérapies classique
enfin chronicles inusité michel merci
scellé